[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vu que le bon il faut lundi le bon ça
suffit la belle allée en l'humain
[Applaudissements]
à
jura
[Applaudissements]
votre fils ensemble et dans ce palais
d'espoir de famille dans un des grands
médias organisé par le comité national
de soutien la candidature de gérard aux
tribunes de ses réunions une éthique
n'en déplaise à qui que ce soit il y
aura comme aujourd'hui de très nombreux
mais il n'y a ainsi dit nous sommes à
cette prime une adresse de vous
présenter la candidature joannie pour ce
qu'elle est simplement une candidature
collective qui veut aider à ouvrir une
nouvelle issue à la crise que traverse
le pays où les verts alors que les
violations villa le candidat des
défenseurs des services publics
le candidat de ceux qui ont dit non le
29 mai dernier le candidat qui veut le
maintien de nos petites écoles dans nos
communes et ce n'est pas un problème de
moralité
j'ai lu j'ai lu ici un article un joueur
parisien qui relate la grève des
postiers de la poste du louvre la
semaine dernière eh bien ils veulent
faire les 30 postes de guichetiers sur
les salaires quand on subit trop je suis
traumatisée par ce que usines y du bourg
voisin qui procurait emploi la
population du village bien
licencié 210 salariés sur 260 sans même
avoir le prétexte l'argument économique
on nous dit quel rapport entre les
maires et la défense des intérêts
ouvriers mais ce rapport il est
historique dans 30 pays
oui les communes sont d'une cellule
essentielle de la démocratie politique
mais depuis deux siècles le combat des
opprimés des exploités inscrit à
l'intérieur de cette conquête
démocratique leur propre conte qu'elle
leur propre existence sociale
dans le cas du ssb qui va de leur école
communale leur bureau de poste leur
maternité de possibilités que les
pouvoirs publics ferment les uns après
jean eyeghe ndong ex the road to work
quel travailleur n'est pas fondée à agir
contre l'union européenne et son pacte
de stabilité qui organise la liquidation
de tous les services publics qui a exigé
la disparition de tous les contrôles sur
les mouvements de capitaux
l'union européenne qui a généralisé la
flexibilité bouleversement la
réglementation sur la durée du travail
les directives européennes sur
l'aménagement du temps trail de 1994
si les travailleurs sont amenés de plus
en plus nombreux alors que nous sommes à
trois semaines d'élections générales
s'ils sont amenés de plus en plus
nombreux à recourir aux moyens
traditionnels de la lutte de classe
c'est parce que eux qui à 60 70 80 % ont
voté voilà moins deux ans pour la
rupture avec l'union européenne sont
absolument convaincus que ceux qui se
présentent à leurs suffrages est con
présente comme assuré de gagner au
deuxième tour ne se poseront jamais
aucun plan de licenciement et que ceux
qui ont voté non le 29 mai 2005 n'ont
d'autre choix que la grêle dans l'unité
syndicale pour le retrait de tous les
plans bilan aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
l'un en précisant pour jour on était des
millions dans la rue il y avait des
centaines de milliers de jeunes
et qu'est ce qu'on demandait avoir un
vrai travail avec un vrai salaire un jeu
sur calvi au chômage 40 % des jeunes
sont en contrat précaire il ya plus
d'étudiants un étudiant sur deux qui
cinq ans après sa sortie de l' attaque
n'a ni travail ni logement
on me parle de sécurité les problèmes
mais j attends des données leur vrai
travail à tous ces jeunes avec un toit
pour se loger et 90% des problèmes
suivants le chili
nous voulons offrir la démocratie et la
démocratie impasse où le pinceau par
l'élection d'une assemblée constituante
qui devrait redonner le pouvoir au
peuple et à la souveraineté de cette
institution par rapport à lui nos veines
@ immédiatement avec toutes les
institutions européennes internationales
et avec le traité de maastricht
[Musique]
merci à toutes et à tous